Harry Potter magic awakened throws a lot
of information out at once and I do not
want you guys to make the same mistakes
I did so here are 10 tips and tricks
about Harry Potter magic awakened that I
wish I knew sooner from strategic card
upgrades to Smart uses of your keys
these game-changing insights will save
you time and prevent crucial mistakes
number one do not upgrade all your cards
at once it can be really tempting to
immediately upgrade every card you have
in your deck to upgrade cards you need
multiple copies of the same card plus
gold at the beginning of the game you
have plenty of gold UI even encourages
you to upgrade cards because this is
essentially how you level up in the game
upgrading your cards will level up your
spell book which is going to boost your
overall stats of course this is
important to do but here's the thing
you'll hit a point in the game where
gold becomes much more difficult to
obtain as the cards become more and more
expensive and the gold becomes harder to
even get it's crucial to upgrade only
the cards that you truly need or
anticipate using in the future focus on
cards that could be used in multiple
decks and invest your resources wisely
now admittedly if you're just starting
out it's hard to know what cards you're
gonna use you don't really know which
cards are good and what kind of deck
you'll want to play so take your time
make your way through the story missions
and only start to upgrade the cards once
you begin finding the ones that you
really like and the ones that you use
frequently a big part of this is also
going to be about if you're more of a
PVP player or a PVE player or if you
want to do both because there are
certain cards that work well in both
decks certain cards that only work well
in PvP and certain cards that only work
well in PVE now speaking of cards that
takes us to number two don't be afraid
to spend your keys there are a lot of
different currencies and rewards in
Harry Potter magic awaken for the most
part you'll want to be very cautious
with how you spin them like in our first
example with the gold silver keys and
gold keys on the other hand are one way
you get new cards to use in your decks
you can earn keys in many different ways
just by completing challenges doing your
daily tasks and completing chapters to
use your silver and gold keys you'll
need to go into the shop and navigate to
the magical studies tab on the left we
have basic study which is where you can
spin Silver Keys one silver key gives
you two random cards of the epic Rarity
or lower now one of the really cool
features here is that even though your
chances of pulling an epic card are
pretty low there is a built-in
protection system that guarantees you'll
get at least one epic card and every 30
draws you can see the little counter
here that keeps track of how many keys
you've used and it works the same way
for the advanced study on the right
which is where you can spin the gold
keys now with the gold keys you have a
chance for Mythic dark or legendary
cards here you'll be guaranteed at least
one of those in every 20 draws now this
guaranteed progress number will reset
each time you get one of those cards so
once you get an epic card from the
Silver Keys it will reset back down to
zero and start counting up again when
you spend more keys same thing for the
gold keys you can also spin your keys
one at a time or stack them to spin
multiple keys at once and that takes us
to number three do not upgrade lower
tier Echoes building card decks are how
you do battle and Magic awaken but
they're only one piece of the puzzle
here you'll reach a point where you
unlock Echoes and to simplify what these
do they're basically special abilities
you can use when battling and you can
really set up your entire deck play off
the ability of your echo in fact that's
what you want to do to be a top tier
player The Echoes come in the form of
iconic witches and wizards from the
series such as Harry Snape Bellatrix
Hermione and plenty of others each of
them has a special ability but what
isn't immediately clear is that each
Echo comes in one of four tiers common
which is gray rare which is blue epic
which is purple legendary which is gold
now why this is a bit confusing is that
each card in the game also comes in one
of these four tiers however the tier is
set for each card so Stupify for example
is always a common card Expelliarmus is
always an epic card and so on now there
are also Mythic cards but as far as I
know right now Ron Weasley is the only
Mythic card in the game so here's why
Echoes are a bit different is because
they can come in any of the four tiers
so Snape for example you can get him as
a common rare epic or legendary and so
for this reason it doesn't make a lot of
sense to upgrade Echoes that are lower
than at least the Epic tier you
definitely want to avoid upgrading rare
or common Echoes as they're not worth
the investment so just be patient and
eventually you'll start getting those
legendary epic Echoes unfortunately
though this is exactly the mistake that
I made I unlocked the Snape Echo and was
like hey this is a really fun Echo I
like how it plays and I upgraded it all
the way to the max well guess what it
was just a common echo which limits the
maximum power of that Echo if I just
waited a bit longer I could have used it
on the rare Snape Echo that I got
shortly after or what I plan to do now
is wait for epic or legendary Echoes now
one additional layer to The Echoes is
that even though their special ability
is always the same there's also a
secondary effect and that's the boosting
of certain cards this special boosting
is random and can change even between
Echoes of the same type when you go to
upgrade an echo you won't be able to see
all of the boosted cards right away
Honestly though if you don't love the
first cards that you see and they don't
match some of your favorite cards in
your decks then it's probably not an
echo that you want to waste your time on
you also want to make sure that the
boosted cards play well with the echo
special ability overall this is not
something I did at all when I upgraded
that Snape Echo so the ultimate goal
here is to gradually upgrade that Echo
let's say you see a few cards that you
really like and that you play a lot go
ahead and upgrade it but don't upgrade
it all the way what you're really
shooting for is you want to have as many
of these cards in this Echo as possible
B cards that you are actually going to
play and use in that deck because then
they're all going to be getting a boost
from this Echo when it comes to
unlocking The Echoes you'll need to know
all about the Forbidden Forest and
that's where number four comes in do not
underestimate the Forbidden Forest the
forest is a treasure Trove of rewards
for both single player and multiplayer
and you can even do that multiplayer
component with NPCs if you'd prefer not
teaming up with real world players when
it comes to the solo Forest runs this is
how you start unlocking new Echoes that
you haven't seen before if you could
reach level 16 that's when you'll unlock
the Bellatrix echo which is widely
recognized as one of the best Echoes In
the game level 5 is another really
important level on the solo Force
because that's when you'll unlock the
Ford Anglia which is a game changer when
you get this essentially it allows you
to earn rewards for free even while
you're away from the game so just think
about this while you're away the car
will be going through the forest
Gathering Echoes and other items how
much it's is able to gather for you is
based on the maximum level you've
completed in the solo Forest so the
further you can progress the better
rewards you'll get from the car now as
for the multiplayer this one is referred
to as the haunted hollow no not Hallows
here you can get one key per day and it
has a chance to be a silver or gold key
even though you can get one per day you
don't necessarily need to do it every
single day it will actually stack up to
seven days so if you miss a few days
you'll be fine as long as you can play
at some point each week and make
progress on unlocking those keys by
completing the run and as I mentioned
before if you don't have anyone online
to play with you can just tap the plus
icon here and add two classmate NPCs to
join you for the Run once you upgrade
your Spellbook to level 20 you'll unlock
the deathly Dell run which is a much
longer run through the forest this one
also has a chance to drop keys and you
get two tries per week on this one both
of those reset every Monday now one more
thing about the forest even after you've
completed all of your runs for the week
it has definitely still beneficial to go
on future runs helping out friends when
you do so you'll get thank you notes of
which you can Farm up to 10 of these per
day with a maximum of 50 per week if you
want to make this really simple you can
even set it to level 1 and just Farm
away you can then redeem these at the
thank you notes gift exchange to buy
monthly Rewards or weekly rewards this
includes trade tokens which are really
valuable because these are going to
allow you to trade cards with other
players even legendary ones if you have
enough to buy a legendary trade token
that is now speaking of rewards number
five don't miss your free rewards of
course Harry Potter magic awakened is a
free to play game so there are going to
be microtransactions to spend real world
money if you choose but you should know
there are many ways to get free rewards
by simply playing the game and keeping
an eye out for your in-game mailbox make
sure to do all of your daily missions
and quests there's even a free item that
shows up every day in the shop so make
sure to claim that every day you log in
there's a magic pass system as well and
even if you don't spend real money on
the higher tier the top row is free to
all players just make sure you go in and
claim the rewards as you unlock them now
with this being launch week for us here
in the US there was also a questionnaire
that I was able to complete that showed
up in my little in-game inbox and also
gave me rewards for completing it and
then if you have it yet this is also
where you will claim all of your
pre-order bonuses which are made
available after creating your character
in Diagon Alley also don't forget about
exploring admittedly the focus of magic
awaken is not on exploring this is not a
game like Hogwarts Legacy where you're
going to try to explore every inch of
the world and the game does have a
really nice fast travel system it's
going to allow you to quickly warp to
just about any activity you choose by
using the map and the menu here on the
left that being said by actually walking
through the castle and even parts of
Diagon Alley on your own you'll come
across items that you can tap to unlock
for free so always be on the lookout for
these when you're taking a class
visiting Diagon Alley or even just
roaming the stairs of Hogwarts for
number six don't miss out on the in-game
help options we said in the beginning
there's a lot of currencies in this game
there's a lot of systems to get used to
but the more I've played I've really
started to appreciate just how many
little tool tips Niantic has included
here now the hard thing is because
there's so much when you first start the
game you really won't know what all you
can click on but try to click on every
icon look at the little eye icon and a
lot of times you're going to be able to
expand this and get get a menu telling
you a lot of valuable information now
this is even more important if you start
to drop some real world money on this
game and even if you're not spending
real world money just when you're using
the keys it will tell you exactly your
odds of getting different types of cards
now that I know about this I've just
been clicking and tapping on everything
trying to read as much information as I
possibly can now there's also a feature
where you can view recommended card
decks so there are a lot of features
within the game itself to help new
players learn some of the deeper
strategies that if you really want to
keep playing the game long term you'll
need to know number seven don't choose
the wrong server the game just launched
globally and because it's an MMO there
are multiple servers throughout the
world they actually just made the
announcement that even the soft launch
servers are now available to all players
so why is the server so important well
if you want to play with friends you'll
need to make sure you're on servers from
the same region note according to the
new post from magical wagon you don't
necessarily have to be on the exact same
server just the same region our servers
within the same region links and can
players add friends and play content
with other players in different servers
within the same region in their answer
yes most servers within the same region
are linked players within the same
Regional servers can add each other as
friends be roommates team up for the
Forbidden Forest and dance club together
note soft launch servers are not linked
to other servers within their region yet
and that's as of June 30th 2023. so if
you do realize you're on the wrong
server you can switch this after the
fact unfortunately you'll need to make a
brand new character to do so thus
restarting your progress your server is
displayed in the bottom left corner of
the game's main menu if you'd like to
switch to a different server simply tap
on the name then choose a new server
from the region you prefer number eight
don't forget your daily duels duels
offer valuable rewards including silver
or gold Keys Gold and Gems make sure to
participate in duels daily and take
advantage of the opportunity to earn
these rewards now if you haven't done a
lot of dueling yet you're probably still
in the novice tier as long as you're in
the novice tier you don't have to worry
about getting matched up against any
real world players so you can play and
learn as much as you want about the
duels while you're in the novice rank
once you hit bronze though you'll start
getting matched up with other players
who are close to the same skill level as
you number nine 9. don't underestimate
joining a social club joining a social
club has been one of my favorite aspects
of the game so far not only do social
clubs provide a sense of community but
they also enable you to trade cards with
fellow members this can really come in
clutch if there are specific cards you
need especially when it comes to
upgrading cards remember in this game
you actually want duplicate cards
because you need multiple copies before
you can upgrade by being in a social
club there's also special activities you
can participate in as a group and also
unlock special rewards there's a club
Adventure activity you can do twice each
day and by working together as a team
you'll unlock rewards for the whole
group there are leaderboards as well so
you can compete against other clubs from
around the world to see how you stack up
we actually still have a few spots left
in our house wreck and tour Club so if
you're looking for an active club with a
lot of eager magic awakened players just
search for house Recon tour once you've
unlocked Social Clubs by playing through
the main missions first come first
served and number 10 don't waste your
gems gems are very very valuable be
careful on where you spin them do not
spend them on Keys first of all that is
an incredible poor value for the gems
even though keys let you open packs of
cards it is just not a good value to
spin your gems here if you're really
focusing on being a free to play only
player then I would recommend only
buying cards that you really play a lot
and if you just started playing the game
you probably don't even know which cards
you're gonna play a lot yet so it
certainly makes sense to save those gems
we have so much magic awakened content
already here on the channel and plenty
more on the way so if you're new here
and want to see more content like this
make sure you hit the Subscribe button
before you go as always thank you all so
much for watching I'll talk to you again
soon